hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com
so for those who don't know me yet i've
been working as a professional trader on
the option market for the past six years
in
hong kong and i've decided to make a
youtube channel a few months ago
because i want to pass the knowledge
guys i want to show you how protraders
are working
what kind of tools and techniques we use
at work at least those that
work for me and most importantly guys i
want to show you
how to use it yourself so in this video
i'm going to
show you how to read the flows and how
to get
information from this on gamestop for
example
let's get into it
[Music]
so very quickly this is gamestop price
and i was saying in all my videos that
i'm very bullish
i was showing you guys this pattern on
the volume
that i see here you can see that the
first period the volume was decreasing
is roughly equal to this period as well
so here i expect
something to happen very soon i don't
know where it's going to come from but
it's going to be something that you know
just exciting
everybody and so everybody is going to
buy i think some gamestop shares
but here what i want to show you guys is
that you know you have different actors
on this market you have professionals
and you have retail
all right and if you know who is doing
what it's actually
easier to predict what can happen
because you know
the difference between those investors
for example we know that hedge funds
there were sellers of gamestop and we
also know
that weirdly when the price is going
higher they become buyers and it's
actually very easy to understand
is just because they have a maximum loss
they cannot exceed so once they
get close to this maximum loss they are
forced by their management
to buy gamestop shares whatever the
price and this is what created this
first
short squeeze that was here guys it's
because there were too much short
interest in this market
and they just needed all together to buy
back the shares
at a crazy price well i want to show you
what
those guys are doing right now because
we know how they're working
we know also that they were sellers so
let me show you this once again i go on
market watch i showed you guys this many
times just go check my other videos
and i record the outstanding shares and
the short interest in terms of shares
and i converted into a short interest
percentage all right
so i'm doing this since i started my
channels and
you have figures every two weeks so i
know there are a lot of discussions
about this short interest this is the
real
short interest and you have also some
synthetic short
that i showed you guys how to compute
yourself which is at spot
so when gamestop is at 200 or around 20
and that is going to 60 if gamestop goes
close to 800
but this is not what i want to show you
guys in this video here
you can see that the short interest was
around 145 percent
in november and that it went to 120
in jen here guys we had this massive
show squeeze alright so
you can see the short interest went from
120
to 40 percent all right in january
between the 15 and 29
and this is when gamestop traded at 4
18. so guys this is
correct data many of you are asking me
is it good or not
like can i trust this data you can guys
i cross check this data
with different uh systems and i can tell
you that this data is correct
i can also tell you that a company that
is listed on the new york exchange
nyse cannot lie about their
short interest if they did it maybe one
time
then the regulator would actually see
that the lied
and they would get the listed there is
nothing worse than being delisted for
those companies so this data is correct
but once again you have the synthetic
shot that is right now around 20
so of course you need to add it all
right but here what i'm interested guys
and that i want to show you is that on
the 15th of march
you got 20 guys and it's just going
lower
every fortnight each time this data is
published it's going
lower so what does it mean it means
something very interesting
it's that actually hedge funds are not
selling so gamestop is now at 200 guys
and they're not selling it if they were
selling it
this short interest would be much higher
so yes
they're selling cool options i know that
but still the short interest is
decreasing
so actually they are not sellers anymore
and
we can understand why it's because some
companies got destroyed you know some
hedge funds
just collapsed because of showing them
stop
so they learned the lesson and they're
not authorized by the management
to short sell gamestop shares anymore
because this is dangerous
for their company so basically those
guys were sellers
and they are not here anymore so you
have no more sellers
guys this is the information i wanted to
show you
and they even become buyers let me show
you this
so this was the massive day gamestop
lost 30
at this level you remember guys the
earnings arrived they were
worse than expected and gamestop lost 30
and here some people bought the dip
but the short interest didn't increase
so what does it mean
and here who was selling guys this is a
hedge fund move all right
we know how they do it you know they
wait for some bad news and they just
sell
all together so this was a hedge fund
sell-off
and here guys yes of course some apes
with diamond hands
both deep but hedge funds bought the
deep as well
so now they're not you know increasing
the short position they're just selling
and buying back lower so they're not
putting any selling pressure on this
price
and i showed you guys that if the price
action develops
higher we're gonna have this gamma
squeeze the short the synthetic shot is
gonna go from 20 to 60 percent
and i showed you guys this as well that
we have here the volume guys look at
this
that are giving me a very nice pattern
so something is telling me
we're gonna see very soon and we have
this april option expiry that is huge on
the upside
so of course i don't know anything for
sure but something is telling me i just
look at the patterns you know it's
repeating itself
once twice it's coming guys it's coming
and
i would say you know around the 7th of
april we're going to have the start
maybe of this new strong move up so of
course i might be wrong
and if i am i would of course do more
videos where i try to explain
what didn't happen as expected but this
is to me quite clear
that the most likely scenario is
definitely we go to 400 480
and like i showed you guys there's going
to be a lot of buying power in this
market if we start to develop higher so
to conclude guys uh we can see
that basically there are no more sellers
that there is a lot of bullish momentum
in the market
uh that we have some upside short gamma
that is going to create some bullish
momentum on the upside
and that we have very big uh
amount of buyers that are retail
investors that believe
uh in gamestop and when you have buyers
and you don't have sellers anymore and
you have this gamma
on the upside you know my only confusion
is that
gamestop needs to go higher so let's
find out let's see if this happens
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys